for more on russia's we're on ukraine
we're joined by ian bremer he's the
president of the eurasia group and g
zero media ian good morning to you
you've been very clear that you believe
russia and putin will succeed from a
military perspective
in ukraine but emerge from that win
damaged seriously on the world stage and
inside russia in other ways what does
that new world look like
that world looks like a continued fight
over ukraine it's it's pretty clear he
can take kiev he can level kiev if he
wants to
but you're going to see millions of
refugees probably 5 to 10 million
refugees ukrainians
across europe
you're going to see the west of ukraine
probably still held by a legitimate
ukrainian government that all of the
west will be not only recognizing
politically but they'll be supporting
economically and they'll be supporting
militarily in other words you know
people keep asking me
how this is going to end and i say well
what do you mean end
because we're not close to a possibility
where we're going to have fighting that
is resolved on the ground in ukraine and
we're going to have much much higher
tensions between nato states and russia
going forward basically what what it
means is that the peace dividend that
the world and particularly europe has
benefited from for 30 years since the
wall came down is absolutely over and
the cost of that the human and the
economic cost of that are going to be
very severe
whether or not putin expected uh the
extent or magnitude of the west reaction
his foreign minister went on the record
and said we'll simply get over this
invasion do you do you one see that
happening and two is there a chance that
like high things like higher gas prices
will cause the west the u.s to pull back
its response
um the latter question is pretty easy i
think this is a sea change for the
governments of the west we see much more
popularity and support for olaf schultz
for example in germany for macron in
france despite the fact that these
countries all have vastly more economic
exposure and their populations do to
russia than the americans do i don't see
any any wavering on the part of the
europeans to spend vastly more on
defense to focus on that as a priority
and to decouple their economies from
russia now the russian response is to
make russia more of a police state and
to remove all dissent 15 up to 15 years
in jail you can get now if you say that
there's a war going on publicly you
can't mention the war it's kind of
insane but the pro you know 150 million
russians are not going to be as easily
cowed as say north korean population is
and so there is going to be ongoing
significant social instability in russia
that putin is going to have to deal with
and repress very severely
ian we have heard a huge call and an
outcry for a no-fly zone to be
established president zielinski has said
it over and over and over again we've
seen nato countries and others providing
the ukrainians with arms but nato has
said no there will not be a no-fly zone
established can you explain why that is
so different and why that will not
happen right now
it won't happen because the united
states and all nato allies have said
consistently that they will not put
troops on the ground in ukraine because
they don't want to risk a direct fight
with the russians that could lead to
world war iii their view is very much
the same on a no-fly zone which would
lead to confrontation directly between
western uh military capabilities and
russian air having said that from the
russian perspective this isn't digital
the russians see uh the the advanced
weapon systems being sent by poland by
the balls by
by the americans to ukraine as acts of
war they see providing real-time
intelligence about the disposition of
russian forces in ukraine letting the
ukrainians hammer them harder as acts of
war those are all significant risks that
nato is taking um i'm not suggesting
that you should take an additional risk
with a no-fly zone but i am suggesting
that the way that putin is perceiving
this conflict is very very different
from the way that we're talking about it
in the united states and with our allies
if nothing else it's a new world order
ian bremer thank you